[Musique]
le tout premier ministre de Terre-Neuve
voit grand le plus vaste complexe
hydraulique au monde étant chantier sur
le fleuve Churchill ou labrador c'est la
promesse d'un avenir prospère pour l'une
des provinces les plus pauvres de la
Confédération le premier obstacle sera
le financement de cette ambitieux projet
l'argent viendra de Londres avec la
création de la British new fandline
Corporation la Brico en 1953 à cela
s'ajoute une expertise québécoise la
Shawinigan Engineering Company le
gouvernement est persuadé la
nationalisation d'électricité est une
grande fructueuse à faire
1962 le gouvernement le sage nationalise
l'électricité au Québec c'est ainsi
qu'Hydro-Québec devient l'actionnaire du
projet de Churchill Falls chez son
voisin faut que ce soit profitable pour
les doses ça peut pas se faire mais pas
question pour Québec de voir les lignes
out tension de son voisin traverser son
territoire sans en conserver la grande
majorité des profits il est donc qui
doit être à la fois acheteur de ce
courant là s'il vient du Labrador et
vendeur s'il doit sortir du Québec à
l'autre bout disant vers le marché
américain ses études-là sont pas
terminées
1966 Daniel Johnson prend le pouvoir il
donne son aval au méga projet les
travaux sont lancés à la hâte avant même
que le contrat ne soit signé en 1969
Hydro-Québec assume les risques liés à
son financement tout en s'assurant une
Mémise sur la ressource jusqu'en 2041
ils ont édifié
fait sans précédent un ouvrage dont
l'envergure est comparable à celle des
pyramides quand l'électricité sort du
fleuve Churchill le Québec l'achète au
prix dérisoire de 0,3 cents le
kilowattheure une véritable aubaine
parce que l'année suivante le choc
pétrolier déstabilise les marchés la
valeur de revente de l'électricité
explose le père de cette historien a
lui-même travaillé sur le chantier de
Churchill Falls dès la fin des années 70
le contrat de chercher le phare n'est
pas vraiment intéressante au terme le
fait que ce soit un contrat qui a été
perçu comme étant inéquitable de
l'apparition de bien tous les premiers
éternels sans son prix à ce contrat
depuis l'origine
50 ans plus tard le contrat a rapporté
près de 28 milliards de dollars au
Québec contre 2 milliards à Terre-Neuve
et Labrador les Québécois gorgnent le
gros lot les terres ne vient n'en
retirent que des miettes et veulent
déchirer le contrat à trois reprises la
Cour suprême va confirmer la validité de
l'Entente ici Jean-Philippe news
Radio-Canada Montréal
[Musique]